[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay something that is wrong and so far
there have been many challengers no
winners nobody's been able to catch us
so far well tonight a fan named Wahid
from Vancouver thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
recent video piece that we did that
involved Steven Tyler this is what he
thought goober is about your show where
you bummed you know Steven Tyler I mean
you know that was fantastic
very good idea but dude this is what you
did
[Applause]
that's the passage area but you couldn't
find like a finer airplane best thing
that that plane can do it like drop
luggage come on back boy this is bad
cause it bad Conan like you were a dog
that had missed the papers yeah no one's
talked to me like that since my father
four days ago
well I'm sorry why he'd you are dead
wrong now true that was a passenger
plane but it was a bomber passenger
plane now I don't blame you for never
having heard of these top-secret planes
known only by the FAA the Pentagon and
myself but they do exist don't just take
my word watch this footage from that
very flight over Gillette Stadium hello
everyone this is your captain speaking
we are right now passing over an
absolute butchering of the national
anthem by Steven Tyler it's just awful
so I'm gonna ask you to go ahead and
take out your undersea bombs and let
them fly thank you very much
[Music]
that proves it if nothing else does by
the way I usually I have a tendency to
make fun of the person who sends in a
correction but while he'd you seem like
a nice normal guy so I'm not gonna do
that what's that oh I'm just being told
that what he'd you added something at
the end of your video that you probably
didn't think we were going to show on TV
let's take a look you know I can do like
you know monkey well correction that's
an eight why he'd
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's now and still stands if you
think you spotted an error on our show
report it team koco.com / haha I found
an error we will sort it out right here
on the air let's see if you've got what
it takes to make chump meat out of the
maestro we'll take a break
[Applause]